merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Philippe Goujon oui monsieur
le Président ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'Intérieur je voudrais
d'abord m'associer bien sûr à
l'indignation de notre collègue fallorni
concernant cette campagne
ignoble de diffamation contre nos
policiers la place de la République
Monsieur le Ministre qui symbolise tant
les valeurs démocratiques et
républicaines célébrées depuis toujours
par les Parisiens représente par
excellence un haut lieu d'expression des
libertés d'opinion et de manifestation
or succédant à des mouvements
d'opposition à la loi et le comerie
plutôt bon enfant au début violence et
dégradation font désormais le quotidien
des nuits debout de graves désordres il
sévisent depuis des semaines au
détriment des riverins et de l'image de
notre ville et de notre pays le mer la
mer de Paris comme les mes des 3e 11e et
plusieurs de nos collègues s'en sont
d'ailleurs émus en dehors de
l'inquiétude même avoir se rassemblé des
centaines et des centaines de
participant en plein état d'urgence dans
un quartier déjà ciblé par les attentats
du 13 novembre comment accepter les
graves débordement de casseurs qui face
à des organisateurs complètement
dépassés s'en prennent presque chaque
nuit aux forces de l'ordre incendiant
même ce weekend un de leurs véhicules
monsieur le ministre allez-vous tolérer
longtemps de telles exactions jusqu'à
quand mobiliserez-vous ainsi tant de
policiers indisponibles pour d'autres
missions et que vous laissez prendre
pour cible dans une quasi impunité le
gouvernement a pourtant su réprimer avec
force d'autres manifestations pourtant
bien moins
violentes combien de dégradations non
dédommagé non dédommagé j'insiste les
riverins et les commerçants devront-il
encore supporter dans l'indifférence des
pouvoirs publics monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur quand procéderez-vous enfin
à l'évacuation tant attendu et
poursuivrez-vous les casseurs qui
abîment l'image de Paris et de la
République merci merci la parole est à
Monsieur Bernard casazenov ministre de
l'Intérieur monsieur le député goujon
comment estce comment pouvez-vous
commencer votre question en rendant
homarge aux forces de l'ordre et
enchaîner immédiatement en oubliant de
préciser que chaque nuit ces forces de
l'ordre font respecter l'ordre dans la
capitale interviennent sur instruction
du préfet de police de Paris procèd à
des interpellations pour que précisément
ceux qui cassent ne puissent pas casser
en toute impunité comment pouvez-vous
passer sous silence que depuis le début
de ces manifestations il y a eu près de
80 interpellations des comparitions
immédiates que le droit est passé parce
que le procureur de la République en
très étroite liaison avec le préfet de
police de Paris déclenche l'action
publique pourquoi laisser à penser qu'il
y a de l'impunité alors que les forces
de l'ordre sous l'autorité de ceux qui
prennent les décisions font tout pour
que les casseurs soient interpellés on
ne peut pas rendre hommage aux forces de
l'ordre et dans le même temps nier à ce
point l'efficacité de leur action
deuxème point vous indiquez monsieur le
député qu'il y aurait une
incompatibilité entre la liberté de
manifester et l'état d'urgence et bien
je vous invite monsieur Jacob également
qui criit beaucoup mais qui ferait mieux
de lire les décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel de lire la réponse du
Conseil constitutionnel à la question
prioritaire de constitutionnalité du 16
février dernier par lequel le Conseil
constitutionnel précise très clairement
que l'état d'urgence n'est pas
l'impossibilité d'exprimer librement ce
à quoi l'on croit et si j'avais interdit
ces manifestations j'aurais été à
l'encontre de ce que préconise le
Conseil constitutionnel la décision
prise aurait été cassée et l'État s'en
serait trouver affaibli et par
conséquent monsieur goujon ce que vous
proposez dans l'outrance c'est
d'affaiblir l'état là où nous nous
voulons le conforter en donnant aux
forces de l'ordre les moyens
d'intervenir par ailleurs je tiens à
vous rappeler également monsieur goujon
que tous les jours nous prenons des des
dispositions pour éviter qu'il est dans
Paris des déampulations qu' conduisent à
des violences nous le ferons dans le
respect du droit nous le ferons dans la
fermeté et nous le nous le ferons dans
le refus de la démagogie et de
l'outrance merci Monsieur le
ministreintérieur